that all comes from the same place of
insecurity of like not believing in
yourself and or over worrying about what
they think about you which one do you
think it is of course the kind of work
hand in hand right something that I
don't like my girlfriend
well let's play it out what if she
breaks up with you you'll be sad you
love her and life continues I guess
you're gonna find someone else you love
yeah it's your natural DNA in
perspective you're letting fear dictate
your actions you're scared yeah that's
okay everyone's scared I'll flip it on
you the fact that you're 18 and mature
enough to understand that fear is real
that's a strike that means you're
halfway home almost another halfway the
other halfway is practicing losing you
gotta start doing [__] that's scary and
have it not work out so you can [__]
taste it got it you understand
absolutely go do something scary go do
something scary put yourself out there